down south the American Atheists group
has put up some controversial billboards
right in time for the holiday season I
think we've got one of the billboards
right here yeah as you can see it's a
little girl penning a letter to Santa
dear Santa all i want for christmas is
to skip church I'm too old for fairy
tales ok so this billboard is now right
now it's in Memphis and Nashville
obviously in Tennessee st. Louis and
Fort Smith Arkansas so they're going
sort of right to the religious people
now things like this have been done
before you guys may remember they did
something like this last year atheists
did sign like this last year in Times
Square certainly not as religious let's
say as the deep south so I think this
brings up a lot of interesting stuff oh
but we've got a quote from the group's
president before we do that even
children no churches spew absurdity
which is why they don't want to attend
services enjoy the time with your family
and friends instead today's adults have
no obligation to pretend to believe the
lies their parents believe that's David
Silverman American Atheists president ok
I've been doing a lot about atheism on
the show and I'm for atheists I think
they get unfairly attacked in this
country relentlessly especially lately
but is this a good move by them like are
they doing a little too much here too
like it's just going to wrangle up the
religious well I think it's important
that a TEENs atheists get recognized and
legitimized more and it's probably good
to have a billboard campaign but i do
feel this one is trying to poke a fight
right it's just going to devolve into
just aggression and not really
understanding which is what we need
right which is sort of what we're seeing
already because now they're getting a
big backlash online on this I mean I
guess timing is everything and they're
purposely doing this right before the
holidays that's also the time when
religious people obviously are feeling a
little more religious little bit more
defensive for a little more defensive
yeah so I may I hate this particular ad
campaign that girls not too old for
fairy tales and she's wack dad and she
should totally believe in Santa because
Santa is great that's it that's an
interesting point we can we throw the
image up again let's look at the image
one more time that is a good point
because there is a certain age right
that that we all believe that children
are
allowed to believe in the tooth fairy or
whatever it is so that girl's probably
what do we think she is maybe 50 my old
kids are let's say eight sure yeah it's
borderline right I guess eat I don't
think kids want to skip church because
they're too old for fairy tales I want
that I think they want to skip church
because it's boring and their kids well
that I guess goes to the quote of David
Silverman who was saying at their their
kids i I just I guess I just feel like
aren't like atheists being atheist is
the easiest thing you have to does not
believe so whenever you can spread the
word of atheism it always seems a little
bit like counterintuitive to me yeah
atheists are gonna be pissed at you
though because they're gonna say it's a
brave choice to not buy into I'm not
snakes on a brave choice i'm saying that
i don't know what the Billboard actually
accomplishes except for crushing the
dreams of a child and i don't mean the
dreams of like Jesus Christ I mean the
dreams of like Santa and uh no she's
writing to Santa well if she's but like
someone's was for your ears Santa's not
real do uh do the non-religious people
in this country need to cook sort of
band together you know we went every
time we do an atheist story always say
you know it's like we've got every group
has even they say well this many black
people vote for this and this many white
people vote for this and this many
Latinos what for this if there's a whole
bunch of non-religious / atheist people
if they had a voting bloc when we do a
lot of good in this country probably but
you know one of the things about
religion is that it's a way to organize
people and galvanize people into one
specific movement and it's a little bit
harder this way and I feel a theism is
really misunderstood by many people yeah
so agree would be she wouldn't lose her
mind if any of her grandchildren said
I'm an atheist right so there's no
unifying force I guess I'm not kind of
the point that's I guess that is the
portion we get behind like an atheist
leader I got like atheist center clearly
we can't you know get bond right but
that I guess is the part of this that
while I agree with the sentiment of what
they're trying to do that's the part of
it that I think might be a little
off-putting like in a weird way they're
sort of becoming by doing something like
a direct attack on this they're just
playing the same game that they claim
that the religious people are playing
right bye-bye sort of mocking someone's
beliefs so I don't know that it's sort
of there's some sort of loop Darth Vader
thing here annoy me
careful about what you become kind of
thing are you with me something say it
reminds me of college when there were
these like it started in high school
these straight edge kids who were like
no drinking the smoking no sex before
marriage very like clean tight and I was
like what happen to them well they all
they all failed sex into drugs no but I
mean like it was one of those things
where I was like you know everyone knows
their options like you don't have to
assert yourself as not doing these
things you can just kind of exist in
that way and people who want to find it
will find in people who want to turn
away from religion will turn away from
religion especially as they get older
and more educated and step away from it
when you proselytize in any way I feel
like it turns people off because it's
exactly what you don't want to be doing
it it's exactly what the opposite side
is doing